foreign
[Music]
a little bit sleepy after the lunch
right it's so hot outside anyway hi
Shelly hershkowitz I'm product manager
in Google Cloud
part of apigee specifically working on
API security I'm really excited to be
here with you
um
let's talk API security
so in today's digital world apis are
becoming one of the most attack frequent
attack Vector out there and in this
slide you can see a few examples of
media headlines
that um sorry media headlines around API
security which are related to API
vulnerabilities you can see brand names
like Tinder Peloton Uber and Optus the
most recent one if you heard about it
you probably ask yourself why why are
API security so popular these days well
apis are the front door for your digital
assets data and business logic so many
of our everyday life activity are
supported by apis if you register your
kid to school whether you check your
bank account balance or if you order
your favorite coffee on your mobile app
in this report businesses and
Enterprises stated that there is a
growth rate of apis on an average of 201
over the last 12 months so think how
hard it is just to track all those apis
make sure that they're secured both
existing apis and the growing one the
new ones and also make sure that there's
no attack on your apis
no breach or some malicious abuse
so why is it so hard to protect apis
first visibility
there are many reports out there that
show that more than half of the
Enterprise's apis will be unmanaged in
the upcoming years if they are unmanaged
you probably cannot control or cannot
put any security tools on top of them
next configuration so we did a survey
with Google cloud between businesses and
Enterprises and we learned that the
number one threat around API security
that businesses are worried about is API
security misconfigurations
next cost
security incidents in general can really
harm your bottom line in this report an
average cost of a breach was analyzed to
be around 4.35 million dollars
and lastly it's really hard to act and
mitigate security incidents in the same
survey we learned that 94 of the people
said that they they believe they have
the right tools to protect from API
security when 62 percent of them stated
that they experienced a security breach
in the last 12 months so they might feel
secure but the data comes and shows
otherwise
let's take a step backwards to those who
are not so familiar with apogee
so apigee's mission is to organize the
world's apis as being part of of Google
basically it's a facade in front of your
apis and workloads wherever they reside
it doesn't matter if they're on-prem in
the cloud multi-cloud deployments
for any use case that you've used you're
using those apis it doesn't matter and
more importantly for any scale so it
doesn't matter if you have only hundreds
of API calls per day or you have
millions of API calls per day you'll get
the same level of service
on top of that we provide strong
analytics too
those analytics come to help the user
operate govern monetize and secure those
apis
and lastly on the platform we're trying
to answer the needs of developers
leaders and security people
so the advantages of using Advanced API
security is that we are part of apigee
platform and already existing strong
platform to govern your apis we are able
to help you manage the entire life
cycles of their apis and we're also
integrated into the gcp ecosystem with
Integrations into many security products
for example you have here on the slide
mendiant Asm on top of that we provide
many security features like risk
assessment abuse detections reports
alerts
um and depth recommendations and best
practices and many more and I'll talk
about it a now
so apogees has two main
components the control plane and the
runtime
Advanced API security is part of the
control plane as such we have visibility
to the entire life cycles of your apis
we also have visibility into the
environment how your apigee environments
are configured and how your API proxies
are configured and we can compare it and
provide recommendation on top of that
according to best practices
secondly we we have visibility into an
already existing analytics data so we
can run abuse detection algorithms and
and logic in order to find any abuse
which is happening on your API traffic
in real time
and lastly we integrate it into the
runtime in order to act in real time to
any suspicious or malicious activity
which is found on on apogee
so what does it mean to have an API
security program
first of all you need to get to make
every API visible right you cannot
control you cannot protect what you
cannot see you need to eliminate any
blind spot on your digital environments
around apis you need to discover all of
them both external and internal apis on
any wherever they reside on multi-cloud
deployments
you need to consolidate them into a hub
into a catalog in order to manage their
life cycle
next once you've found all your apis and
you're sure you don't have any blind
spot you need to make sure that you have
a consistent standards of security
across all those apis existing apis and
of course a future upcoming apis you
need to make sure that you can assess
the risk for each API and if something
is misconfigured you want to be able to
take action on it in the platform in
order to get it back to be with a strong
security posture
so after you found on your apis you make
sure that all the security policies are
in place for that you need to make sure
that a you can detect any abuse which is
happening on your apis if your API is
experiencing some abnormal traffic or
some abnormal activity you need to be
able to to identify it
and it identify it understand it quickly
in order to act on it
so if you found some suspicious activity
you want the system to be able to act on
it maybe flag some suspicious activity
maybe redirect the traffic maybe you
want to deny the traffic so actually
within the platform you want to be able
to act on it
so let's take a look how we can help the
can how we can help you get more
visibility into your API landscape
so the idea here is where you're going
to utilize Mandy and ASM mainly and
attack surface management
has more than 250 built-in integrators
in order to identify any external facing
assets when I say assets I I mean
virtual machines host names IPS open
ports and of course open
apis public facing apis it also adds a
lot of information on top of those
findings in order to help you understand
what they are like severity or active
checks
what we do is we take all those API that
Mandy and ASM found and we push it into
a API hub
so think of API Hub as a universal
catalog of all your apis again doesn't
matter where they reside whether they
are hosted on apigee on other API
management platform in public clouds
doesn't matter where they are everything
is is streamed into the API hum
the basic idea behind the Hub is to
empower Empower your developers to reuse
existing apis instead of creating their
own on each time
and API Hub helps manage the the API
life cycle so from design from design
planning pre-production production until
end of life with all the information
around that
so okay so now we we were able to find
all those API consolidate them into an
API Hub now you should be able you
should make sure you can have ensure
consistent security standards on top of
them and that's what we're coming in
with this feature so the idea here is to
help the user adhere all their API
proxies to security standards both
internal and external in order to avoid
any misconfigured apis that might lead
to data leaks
the system evaluates each API proxy and
environments is how it's defined and
also as scores it and also gives the
recommended actions of what should be
put in place what policies what security
policies you should put it place in
order to improve your security posture
as much as I like those dashboards and I
think they're pretty I don't expect you
to actually sit in front of the
dashboard and so we are also connected
it to Cloud monitoring Cloud monitoring
enables the user to get notifications if
something is happening in your
environment so let's say that you have
an API proxy a payment proxy a highly
sensitive and you want to make sure that
if something changes on that
configuration you a you're going to get
an email or a slack notification that's
what you can do here you can define
those kind of alerts to let you know if
something is misconfigured you can jump
into the product and get understanding
get recommended actions and fix it
this this is also connected to Pub sub
so you can push all this information
into Pub sub for example if you want to
connect it to any ticketing system that
you might have
and everything that you see here is
accessible or through also through API
so you also can access it that way
okay so let's see a short demo a
around that
so what you see here you see my my
security scores in apigee in apogee
environment you see all my
environments where their risk level with
the security his score and you see the
number of recommended actions for each
for each environment
now we what we we can do is jump into
the specific environment let's look at
the local environment first of all you
can see the top highlights for each
assessment so we have three types of
Assessments as part of the score Source
proxy and Target each one is focused on
another
um another set of assessments so for
example the proxy looks at how the proxy
is assessed sorry which policies the
proxy holds you can see they were in the
distributions of the of the API proxies
under the specific environment according
to the risk level so you can also see
that
and now you can also jump into the
assessment page to get more details so
first of all you can get details of the
assessment what exactly was evaluated
but more importantly you can get a list
of all your API proxies in a dedicated
risk level and score for each proxy with
the recommended action so for example
this test one proxy has authorization
a authorization recommendation which
means that the system suggests that
you'll add one of the following policies
in order to improve your security
posture
that's what I thought would happen okay
Okay so
now that you found all your apis you
made sure that everything is configured
correctly you have all the Securities
policies on top of them you want to make
sure that everything is operating
securely in runtime so it make you want
to be able to identify any abuse or
business logic attacks or attacks that
Focus to extract data from your apis
for that I'm really excited to tell you
about the new machine learning models
that were recently released these models
are a
Google owned models were trained and
maintained and supported by Google to
identify specifically scraping attacks
and anomalies
and so this is again this is the way for
Google to share the security and machine
learning know-how and bring it to the
hands of the customers now we also added
in product close to real-time dashboards
in order to show the attack landscape
and only today I talked with the
customer who told me that security
people likes like like dashboards so we
have also dashboards here and
we we also added clustering algorithm on
two those dashboards in order to Cluster
the detected traffic in order to or in
order to reduce the the amount of
traffic detected in order to help the
user focus on the most sensitive and
critical incidents and we also added a
lot of context for each incident that we
find and for example we enriched today
the traffic we're playing to University
even more with threat intelligence
information so the whole idea here is to
help the user with them in a matter of
seconds
to actually understand if there is a
security incident if it needs their
attention if they need maybe to involve
other people in in the in this incident
okay so all the detected traffic that we
the rules that we just saw everything is
supported by a strong reporting
capabilities so you can customize create
any reports you want in order to show to
see what was detected by the traffic
again everything is accessible through
apis and you can also
um get the information from the apis and
stream it to any Sim that if you're
working to create your own dashboards
and to correlate it with also other
security products that you might have
okay so now that we we had we have more
visibility into the uh to the traffic
patterns on the apis and in apigee now
what we want to do is if we find some
suspicious activity we want to be able
to act on it and again this is one of
the advantages of advanced API security
because we're part of a API of apigee of
the API management platform we're able
to integrate into the runtime in a
really efficient way with minimal
latency impact on the on the runtime in
order to actually take action on the
traffic
so what we offer here is the user will
be able to act on suspicious traffic
whether it's to
um flag it for Downstream
workloads or flag it to in order to
correlate it with others
in your sim with other a alerts security
alerts that you might have you'll be
able to deny traffic if you decide that
it's malicious you you are able to
redirect the traffic and everything
within the apigee platform
so I guess we have a demo for that
I'm sorry I don't have a demo to show an
attack I promise you next next I'll do
that I'll just have a demo that will
show you how uh the the policy is being
configured in in apogee
so here you can see I'm going to create
a new action I'm going going to call it
next demo
what I want to do is I want to deny the
traffic for a from everything that was
detected as the um ml scraping by the MS
scraping model
I'm going to apply it on my environment
default test I'll set the expiration
that way it will never expire
and now I'm going to choose the action
that I want to use so there are a you
could see allow deny or flag you can see
here that I'm using with flag we're
adding a header name and a header value
so you can add this header to the
detected traffic in order to you know
maybe do with it something with this
information in your Downstream workloads
oh no I thought I didn't want to happen
okay
sorry for that
okay here
so this is flag but no I want to deny
the traffic from the MS scraper so I'm
going to choose that
now I'm going to choose a predefined
message to the client that was denied
you can choose I'll choose 404 just to
hide the the reason that I would
rejected the request I can choose the
set of conditions so it's currently it's
IPS and detected rules
um I'll choose the new Advanced API
scraper I can also you see create other
conditions in order to have a more it
sensitive and tuned rule
now I'm going to create I created it
that's great I can see it in my list of
rules
um and now I'll see that it the rule
exists here it will see also that it's
enabled of course we can disable it if
we want we also added a dashboard to
show the uh the action itself so here we
get more information about the action
but we'll also we can also look at the
traffic of the action of the how the
traffic was impacted in the last two
weeks of course nothing was detected and
denied because we just created the
action but basically you'll be also be
able to see any traffic that was acted
on with this with this new policy
okay
great so um
to sum it up basically in apigee we
believe in shift
shifts left and shift down shift left
aims to help the a to help scale
security people
right you see I talked with many
customers they taught me that tell me
that security teams are pretty small
they need to scale they need to bring
more tools into the hands of the API
developers and API API management owners
so we are trying to do that and with a
lot of security configuration automation
around that alerting notification
everything in order to bring more tools
into the hands of the API owners around
security and shift down we mean that we
actually want to put everything more
push it towards the platform
that the platform will serve you that it
will detect things automatically with
detect enemies configuration or any
abuse we let you know we'll also give
you the recommended actions what you
need to do in order to improve your
security posture and and get back in
line to a strong a strong API security
posture
hey thank you very much for joining me
today and it was a pleasure for me if
you have any questions I'm here after
the presentation
[Music]
foreign